bonjour voila je suis vraiment heureuse
de vous voir aujourd'hui
particulièrement la journée a été calme
tellement calme que je commençais à
m'ennuyer
casilli on n'est même pas venu me dire
bonjour enfin heureusement que vous êtes
là vous savez certainement des cas
d'histoire à me raconter
qu'à d'ériger fabien tu m'as laissé seul
toute la journée
enfin je suis bien content de pouvoir
quand même
tiens regarde je vous ai trouvé qu est
ce que c'est c'est très joli c'est une
boîte car oui je vois bien une boîte
mais de quoi enfin il coûte une écoute
jamais ce que je raconte je te dis que
je les trouvais à bombay ou dans le
petit bois sur la mousse au pied du
grand chêne ça alors je me demande
vraiment comment elle a pu arriver là il
a peut-être poussé comme un champignon
à kazimiyah voyons ces objets là ne
pousse pas comme des champignons il faut
les fabriqués avec du bois et des clous
oui qu'est ce qu'il peut bien y avoir
dedans mais je ne sais pas il faudrait
il faudrait nourrir et bien voilà il ya
un petit crachin la rue mais c'est
peut-être dangereux dangereux pourquoi
j'ai peut-être un animal féroce de danse
ça on est puisqu'elle appartient
peut-être à quelqu'un qui serait très
mécontent de voir qu'on l'a ouvert ça
c'est vrai toit raison juge je vais
aller me renseigner à tuer casimir ta
bombe h la cave
elle est vraiment très jolie
si c'était à l'intérieur est aussi
enfin nous pensons plus
j'ai certainement quelque chose à faire
moi
[Musique]
non mais rien à faire du tout
il est trés face aux petits crochets
il n'y a personne
venez venez monsieur dassault c'est par
ici très bien bonjour ma très chère amie
humains jumeaux quelle merveille un os
cette boîte est splendide
quel agilité dans le dessin quelles
couleurs chatoyantes
chatouillant tu qu'elle snap ce monsieur
du 6 novembre je n'ai pas dit
chatoyantes robin lourds jeudi chatoyant
rima signifie qu'elle a des couleurs qui
brille elle fait partie de votre
collection d'objets d'art monsieur du
centre je vous félicite vous avez
beaucoup de boue malheureusement ma très
chère amie
cet écrin ne m'appartient pas du tout
c'est un écrin bon qu'est-ce que c'est
un écran nous envoyons casimir c'est une
boîte qui contient des bijoux des bijoux
bijoux de langues riham en deux temps
jeudi paroisse organique
on a pu croire arrivés pour ce qu'il
attendait mais elle appartient peut-être
moselle futé cette chaire aide mais a dû
la laisser tomber de son sac lorsqu'elle
leur rechercherait des flyers le petit
doigt mais vous avez raison monsieur du
sna oui je n'y avais pas pensé je vais
vite la chercher nous la trouverons
certainement dans le petit bois jean
jaurès et des jolis oui part à droite
moi à gauche d'abord aller
je t'avais dit à gonchar que le toupet
quelle merveille qu'est l'agilité
qu'elle doit t quelle histoire quelle
belle journée mais
bon ça fait peur
oui pas nerveux comme ça on peut poser
leurs chevaux chocolat
chaud chocolat quelqu'un de chocolat à
la mairie monsieur l'islam monsieur
layton ne faites pas comme si de rien
n'était je sais très bien que dans votre
dos vous avez une boîte de chocolats et
ce sont eux et rien à craindre de moi je
suis je suis pas gourmand mais vous
attention à la crise de foie on a là
attention attention un gros gones ont un
peu gourmand
des chocolats
et s'il avait raison
en tout cas cette boîte ne lui
appartient pas
mais du calme a pas d'affolement de la
méthode oui j'ai failli on voit
il n'y a apparemment
pas de nom pad adresse
pas de ficelle
et bien comme dirait le facteur il ne
s'agit pas d'un colis postal non mais je
suis désolé je n'avais jamais vu cette
boîte auparavant elle n'appartient pas
non plus à françois bon
on parle de moi à oui oui le cher ami je
puisse vous dit tout à l'heure que cette
boîte ne m'appartenait pas et qu'il n'y
avait pas de chocolat à l'intérieur mais
qu'y at il alors
le chocolat est bienvenue mais je
comprends rien moi mon frein tous
ensemble comme ça des coups de feu soit
c'est casimir qui a trouvé cette boîte
et elle n'appartient à personne personne
quand même pas tombé du ciel cette boîte
et pourquoi pas que veux tu dire eh bien
les gens de la terre râpées pour moi
bien des fusées dans l'aliment alors
pourquoi est ce que les gens de la lune
n'enverrait pas des boîtes de toutes les
couleurs sur la terre
c'est joli ce que tu deviennes dire mon
petit canard il
est peu probable
moi je ne vois qu'une solution laquelle
c'est l'ouvrir bravo eh bien ma chère
amie
avons l'honneur
l'idée de vous alors très vite donc
voilà
au
poisson
au gaz
[Musique]